Are you a member of the Galactic Empire?
Am I being detained?
Because I know my rights.
My partner there is telling me that his womp
rat has signalled on your vehicle.
That is bullsh- your partner just tapped my
speeder-
Step out of the speeder, and I'm going to
need to see your identification.
You don't need to see my identification.
I rise to speak until I can speak no more
about this government's unauthorized use
of droid strikes.
You can't be the guy who builds this,
you can't be the corporation that builds this.
You have to be an empire to build something
like this.
It takes government leadership,
to build a battle station the size of a moon
that can obliterate inhabited planets.
And it doesn't matter if it's bulk metadata
or not
who you're sending holograms to is information
about you and your personal life.
Where are those transmissions you intercepted?
Well, in my defense I'm not handling anything
anymore
that's been passed to the journalists.
You are part of the rebel alliance and a traitor.
There are 14 individuals frozen in carbonite,
20 years latter,
and they've never had a trial.
Commence eminent domain.
Let's at least audit the Imperial Reserve.
I'm just saying it's a slippery slope from
gay marriage to incest,
I swear to you I just saw a woman kissing
her own brother.
I have apologized for saying 'sand people'
in my older news letters,
that was a different time,
I want you to know that today I have many
indigenous Tuskan peoples
on my staff and as my friends.
Ten thousand, all in advance.
Ten thousand?
Could almost buy our own ship for that.
The government has increased the cost of risk
and so our supplier is increasing the cost
of his services.
It's basic economics Luke.
We're gonna do a little bit of light saber
work
and then I'm gonna have you read a lot of
Milton Friedman.
The Imperial Environmental Protection Agency
has sixty thousand storm troopers.
Why do they need imperial walkers to protect
forestation on Endor?
The only thing that can stop a bad guy with
a gun,
is a good guy with a gun who shoots first.